Don't you see I'm cursed to this ship?
That's why I'm here.
I think I know a way to break your curse.
To free you from The Dutchman.
Henry. No.
I've read about a treasure.
A treasure that holds all the power of the sea.
The Trident of Poseidon can break your curse.
Henry
The Trident can never be found.
I found you!
It's just a tale.
Like the tales of you and Captain Jack Sparrow?
He will help me find The Trident.
You stay away from Jack.
Leave the sea forever.
You have to stop acting like a--
A pirate?
I wont stop.
I want you to come home.
Oh, hi Jack Sparrow.
Jack Sparrow.
Spanish?
You're, uh,  ghosts.
Oh, they aren't able to step on land
I knew that though.
Ghosts!
Help!
Carina!
You will soon pay for what you did to me.
There's no need to bother, really.
Carina!
I have no time to chat because my map just ran away.
I will be waiting. For you.
Why would you be waiting for me?
Why would he be waiting for me?
I'm looking for a pirate. Jack Sparrow.
Bugger off.
Psst. I need to speak with you.
Hand me your sword.
I don't have a sword.
What kind of soldier has no weapon?
I'm currently wanted for treason.
So not the very good kind then.
I'm looking for a pirate, Captain Jack Sparrow.
Well today is your lucky day.
Cause I just happen to be
Captain
Jack
Sparrow
No, it can't be.
I've spent years searching for...
this?
The great Jack Sparrow is not some drunk in a cell.
Do you even have a ship? A crew?
Pants?
A great pirate does not require such intricacy.
Do you know how long I've been waiting for this moment?
The risks I've taken to be here.
Are you sure you're the Jack Sparrow?
How would you like to die, pirate?
Hanging?
Firing squad?
Or a new invention?
The guillotine.
Guillotine? Sounds French.
I love the French. Did you know that they
invented mayonnaise?
How bad could it be, it's French eh?
Oh.. very bad ..
Uh.. I've changed my mind!
Here's an idea!
Why don't we try a good old-fashioned stoning, eh?
I'll kill Wisdon right now, gets the crowd involved, doesn't it?
I should like to speak to Victor in  Disembowelment! I should like to speak to him!
Pardon me.
I, I'm not one complain normally but this basket's full of heads.